now i think we can all agree that it's
been a very stressful week in america in
fact there are a lot of things in life
that are stressful whenever life is
stressing me out i like to take a moment
and gaze at the stars
whoa
a shooting star i think i'll make a wish
on it
[Music]
i wish dogs could talk
oh another one i wish onions made you
giggle instead of cry
i wish santa had a soul patch
wow
i wish astronauts could bring a plus one
i wish every time you farted it sounded
like the trumpet they play when a king
enters
[Music]
excuse me
[Applause]
when it comes to getting vaccinated i
wish people had a choice get vaccinated
or get punched in the face
oh there is
i wish queen latifah the best she's
great
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa i wish the scale at my doctor's
office was set between zero and you're
happy and that's what matters
[Applause]
oh whoa
one more
stars i'm shocked
i wish dunkin donuts was a basketball
team of donuts who could dunk
[Music]
oh
i wish michael buble was pronounced
michael bubble
oh
i wish they would cuss more in
commercials like taco bell come get
these tacos
oh
i wish there was a bow tie family that
my bow tie could go to
after the show
oh there is
oh
look there's the bow ties partner and
two kids
they're so proud of my bowtie
my wish came true
ah
now that's some a plus wishing
[Music]
you